we're gonna be collecting centuries or
the striped bark scorpion and this
Canyon is full of them
scorpions are nocturnal they come out at
night they fluoresce under UV light and
we will use the light to spot them and
then we use forceps
so I probably started collecting
scorpions in 1999 when I was in graduate
school first year of graduate school and
I was mostly working by myself on a very
small scale we collect the scorpions
because we need the venom because part
of what we do is just to actually
isolate the individual toxins from the
venom and then study how they manipulate
our nervous in our neuromuscular system
how do they cause pain and potentially
death
it's an integrative project and it's on
a huge scale we go from cell to
ecosystem I could not do what I do
without the help of a lot of
undergraduate graduate students and my
husband who is my collaborator and
colleague so I study a group of
scorpions that belong to the genus
centroid East
commonly known as the Bart scorpions and
they make venom that is intensely
painful some people describe it as the
feeling or sensation of being burned
with a cigarette or being branded and
that could be followed by a sensation
you feel like somebody's hit you with a
hammer so an intense throbbing pain so
in the other corner the predator on
these scorpions is a scorpion mouse
belongs to the genus Aine kameez and
they attack and kill and eat these
scorpions and they can get stung during
their interactions but the scorpion mice
are actually resistant to the toxins
that would not only kill them but the
toxins that cause us through this
intense pain we feel like if we can
understand that mechanism at the
biochemical and the molecular and the
physiological level we might be able to
develop better pain treatments that shut
down pain signals without being
addictive or having lots of unpleasant
side effects
okay yeah so what we've been doing right
now is just coming out here during the
day before it gets dark and planning
what we're gonna do tonight the kind of
habitat where you find the most bark
scorpions tends to be sort of a middle
band along along a hill a lot of cactus
small bunch grass so hopefully the
weather will hold good rain might be
beautiful might not get over 100 it's
always a it's a gamble but the scorpions
are not aggressive they will try to go
to the opposite end of a terrarium I'm
more worried about someone getting
bitten by rattlesnake or falling
downhill and breaking an ankle or a leg
so so there are other things that we
worry more about probably the cactus the
sharp spines on the cactus so we have
lots of talks about safety the general
rule is if it's smaller than a quarter
we'll leave it alone he's way too small
first so sometimes if they run if you
blow on them really hard they just stop
and I think it's just because it just
overwhelms them with like this sensory
overload yips
nice yeah it's about 26 ever good joy
I'm sure the guys are through there will
come back with like hundred in their bag
or something we have so many questions
that are unanswered and not just the
scorpion venom there are so many
questions about the evolution of the
toxins and how they work just the
physiology the biochemistry and when you
get out here you realize the desert it's
alive just the diversity of animals it's
the diversity of interactions among
those animals and the interesting
ecosystem for me having a project region
Depot fieldwork and lab work is just
exciting you know I can see myself being
out here until I can no longer get out
here I know the best job in the world
I also study dreams because I'm
fortunate to be working in a dream a
nightmare laboratory and our lab is
pretty special in the sense that there
are a lot of sleep labs around the world
but it's pretty rare to have a lab
specifically dedicated to scientific
study of dreaming